los partidos de organizaciones sostienen
que hoy finaliza el mandato de moix pero
él insiste en que le falta un año en el
poder en qué consiste en que erradica
estas diferencias y que no es por favor
la diferencia será rica
y ellos los de los opositores solamente
miran para el poder pero en sí la
constitución es tan clara que el mandato
del presidente finaliza el próximo año
sí señor
por otro lado colectivos de oposición
acusan al presidente de aferrarse al
poder y de agravar la crisis económica
que se vive en el país estas detenciones
podrían considerarse como otro paso en
esa dirección de supuestamente aferrarse
al poder
no creo porque si ustedes miran bien
eeuu la oea ellos todos están de acuerdo
que la hermandad del presidente termina
el próximo año lo que pasa las
estaciones que se hicieron hoy hubo hace
mucho tiempo desde que empezó ellos
bloquearon el país porque porque ellos
tenían sus intereses mezquinos en cuanto
a contratos como electricidad que el
país nunca tuvo electricidad algunos de
ellos estaban cobrando mil millones de
dólares para algo que nunca existió
desde un principio la violencia
bloquearon el país y entonces no es que
sea que el saz era al poder hasta que
pasa 7 de febrero 2022 podemos decir que
se hace
bueno pero también hemos visto durante
meses pues de esas ciudadanas en puerto
príncipe y en diferentes ciudades de
este país donde la comunidad denuncia
una crisis económica muy fuerte donde
denuncian falta acceso a la salud a la
educación en general un país en crisis
que nos puedes ir entonces usted desde
la relación entre la posición del
gobierno y esta ciudadanía que reclama
mejores políticas públicas para la
ciudadanía
muy buena pregunta este este problema
económica que tiene que tiene del país
el residente actual no es el solo
culpable de lo que está pasando en el
país tenemos un país desde hace muchos
años que un poquito un grupito pequeño
se apoderan del poder económico sobre
todo siempre ellos colocan un una
persona de color
una persona de color va a poder como
gobernar detrás de esta persona